[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
ah
back to nelson
rejected and that goes out of bounds
they'll keep possession
to the paint
ask lebron
stripped away
nelson outside
brown right side
nelson outside
[Applause]
[Applause]
dishes at the nelson
and you know they wanted that one to go
down
let's prove a time fourth quarter don't
get it done now
no more chances
man he's having quite the quarter
converting
at a really high percentage
and so out of bounds it goes and they'll
keep possession
brown with the bounce pass
blocked again
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's stolen by brown
well this guy has been efficient and
effective all night that
iq has been on display
and he's really been dialed in here down
the stretch five of seven
from the field
right wing
always going up for the alley-oop here
passes it to nelson
the pastor brought
there's the steal and there's a whistle
that goes on brynn fours
that's foul number two for him he needs
to get himself under control here that's
two fouls
in less than 60 seconds
picked his pocket
[Applause]
nelson right side
pass to brown down low
out to the right wing
the dish to nelson to the middle
boy in a close game it's nice to have
him on your side he's gone seven of nine
here
in the fourth to give them some life
and you can see what the emphasis was at
halftime here in the second
a lot more effort to get the ball inside
and it's starting to pay dividends
it's stolen
excellent excellent box out there
keeping himself between the man
and the basket
inside
pastor brown nelson outside
[Applause]
on the wing brown
passes it to nelson
out to the wing
oh and there's the alley oh that is just
nasty about the
athleticism on that finish nice
he feeds it to brown
[Music]
and there's the pass to nelson
not shot from outside there's no doubt
about that spreading the floor
and getting them up
kicks it to nelson up top brown
nelson outside
out left of the wing
[Applause]
[Applause]
and he is one cool customer guys isn't
he
every possession magnified down the
stretch but he's been ready
with only one miss against his six makes
to the inside
[Applause]
sensational block really starting to
attack on the interior
here showing a much more physical
presence here in the second half
tonight
snatched away he has not
missed a shot in this quarter they've
tried running different things in him
but he's been unstoppable
well they're not behind because of this
guy he is putting on a tremendous run
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so the left wing
out left of the wing
there's the steal
easy chance for mid-range wouldn't be
surprised to see them run that play
again
it's just what the doctor ordered here
boy have they needed him
here in the fourth
to the right side
[Applause]
and certainly they are not hesitating
letting it fly
from deep here in the second half
and he lobs it up toward the rim
and how about the performance we're
seeing from him not one miss
on the day
in case anyone was wondering this is
what it looks like when you're in the
zone he hasn't missed one
all quarter
[Applause]
on the wing jackson
riding the hot hand and why not if
something's working
keep going to it out to the right wing
and guys i like what they're doing here
in the second half getting a lot of
production
in the paint and still trailing but but
starting to show some grit
down low
and he is one cool customer guys isn't
he
every possession magnified down the
stretch but he's been ready
with only one miss against his six makes
pastor henry
and you can just see the confidence
level growing with each shot that he's
made that's now
five of five here in the fourth
adding to this lead he's been dependable
and consistent at the offensive
end
pastor jackson
i mean he has been unreal here down the
stretch nine of ten
in the fourth quarter i just don't know
if the game can be played
any better
he is on a mission that's eight of nine
here
from the field in the fourth the pass to
newton
[Music]
you